i'll take it over from here well 3 500
firefighters from across the country are
out there to help with the blaze
including two of our departments here in
southern nevada the fire started two
weeks ago and it's getting worse the
calder fire ripped through more than 200
thousand acres of property forcing
thousands to leave their homes behind
not knowing if they'll be standing when
they return after 15 days just 20
percent of the fire has been contained
these are pictures shared to us by
captain david carraway from the north
las vegas fire department he and his
team arrived there yesterday caraway
says the smoke is so thick they can't
see anything around them
walk outside you really kind of just
want to
you know and kind of clear your throat
because you can feel that ash and the
smoke that's all around you just kind of
it creates like almost a tingling
sensation in the in the like the right
at the top of your chest where your
lungs are
members of the clark county fire
department are also there as of right
now they're picking up duties at the
local fire department usually would
handle like medical calls or structure
fires but they are ready to battle the
wildfire when called the units are
expected to be there for at least two
weeks but that could change reporting
live from the newsroom victoria saha 8
news now